if you want to be successful mindset is
everything the reason that mindset is so
important is at the end of the day only
execution matters so if you have big
dreams if you have goals something that
you're trying to accomplish in your life
you're going to have to execute against
that so why do I say that mindset is so
important in that scenario the reason is
that ultimately to achieve the things
you want to achieve I can promise you
when you start out you're not good
enough yet to achieve that and or you
don't have the right plan and so the way
to refine the plan to actually do the
thing that you want to accomplish you're
going to have to run through what I call
the physics of progress the physics of
progress are very simple they require
you to have a hypothesis which is simply
your best guess this is what I think I
have to do to achieve my goals then
you're going to turn that into something
you can do you're going to do that thing
it's going to fail to some degree that's
just the way it works but failure is the
most information Rich data stream on
planet Earth but to accurately assess
the data and figure out what it's
telling you about why you failed to some
extent you have to be willing to stare
nakedly at your own inadequacies take
responsibility for the outcome not make
it somebody else's fault you're never
going to be able to learn the lesson you
need to learn in order to improve your
behavior so that you can then execute
better and make more progress hey it's
Evan Carmichael and I make these videos
because the thing that saved me as an
entrepreneur was watching the stories of
other successful entrepreneurs and I
learned from their advice I learned from
their motivation and honestly I have no
idea where I would be if I didn't have
those videos to inspire me I still need
them for myself today too and I hope
that they can inspire you as well so
today let's learn how you can never give
up and fix your mindset enjoy thank you
that really is it that's the physics of
progress hypothesis
turn it into something actionable run
that action learn from the partial
failure get a little bit smarter
come up with a new hypothesis that is
more informed turn it into something
actionable run that it will fail again
to some degree figure out why by
lowering your defenses having a growth
mindset making sure that you are able to
take on the responsibility now why is
that a mindset question why can't you
just run that equation if it really is
that simple the answer is you have in
your brain something called the
psychological immune system this is
something given to you by millions of
years of evolution we should all be
extremely grateful for it and the
psychological immune system's job is to
make sure that you don't commit suicide
it is designed to make you feel better
about things it's the reason why you can
mess up make a mistake and you can
soothe yourself now the problem is that
the goal of the psychological immune
system is not for you to achieve your
goals it's simply to make sure that you
feel good enough about yourself that you
can keep moving through life
now the reason that that becomes wildly
problematic and is one of the most
important things you have to address in
your mindset if you're going to be
successful is because the number one
tool that your psychological immune
system works to soothe your ego is to
make everything somebody else's fault it
is the fault of the government it is the
fault of rich people it is the fault of
not being born the right color not being
born the right sex so on and so forth it
is making something the external problem
now here's the really bad news your
psychological immune system is going to
grab for a very valid excuse those
things that I listed may all be true
they may really all be holding you back
the problem is you want to know what the
right mindset for success is and if you
want to be successful you are going to
have to overcome a endless parade of
problems and to overcome the endless
parade of problems you have to have a
way to take responsibility
for what you can do differently to
overcome those problems instead of being
annoyed instead of shutting down instead
of just pointing the finger you want to
adapt your behavior it sucks that the
second law of Thermodynamics is that all
things move towards chaos
it sucks that humans are so complicated
and so weird that we don't just lift
each other and love each other which we
do and is amazing we tear each other
down we kill each other man read history
books it will terrify you about how
brutal humans can be it is crazy how
many different times and places
throughout history we have just
slaughtered people in Mass numbers in
the most horrifying way that you can
possibly imagine so if humans can slide
all the way to that level of depraved
Madness and we know that everything
moves towards chaos how do we bring the
massive amount of order
that we have to bring to the world so
that we can March ever long towards
success and actually achieve it
the only way to overcome chaos the only
way to overcome entropy which is the
fancy name for chaos is to pour energy
into the system so you have to
constantly pour energy into your own
life to make sure that you're making
progress to your goals if you're going
to eventually achieve success and the
only way that you're going to be able to
do that is to have a growth mindset now
really simply a growth mindset is that
you believe that your talent and
intelligence are not fixed traits that
you can get better at something as you
put time and energy into getting better
at that thing it's what I call the only
belief that matters the only belief that
matters is that by applying time and
energy into something you will actually
get better at it now once you believe
that everything in your life Downstream
of that gets better because now you know
oh I messed up at this thing I suck at
that thing the world is trying to stop
me from doing that thing the world is a
effective at stopping me from doing that
thing a word all I need to do is go and
get better and I can outperform people
as Kobe Bryant said and this has become
my favorite quote in the world
booze don't block dunks now what did he
mean by that he meant
that no matter what you can get so good
that people can't stop you
people were paid millions of dollars to
stop Kobe Bryant from scoring points and
yet he scored 81 points in a single game
just by getting better than other people
getting better than other people
requires you to have a growth mindset
that's the growth part you're going to
get better
so that when you fail and you will fail
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over again and it's going
to be embarrassing it's going to hurt
and all that but when you fail
if you believe oh failing means that I'm
a failure because my talent and
intelligence are fixed traits there's
nothing I can do to get better you will
stop why wouldn't you it's the only
thing that makes sense
but if on the other hand you believe
that oh
I can get better at this I'm not good
enough yet but I can get good enough by
applying time and energy into getting
better so now you'll apply that time and
energy because you believe that it will
yield the outcome that you want and that
is why it is so critical to get your
mind right so that you can run that Loop
of the physics of progress because watch
how it breaks down if you don't have a
growth mindset I have a hypothesis hey
this is what I need to do I'm going to
try this thing I tried it oh my God I
failed it's embarrassing I'm hurt
emotionally people are making fun of me
my parents are telling me I told you so
oh my God like I don't want to keep
going and by the way this is making me
really feel badly about myself so now
I'm going to Stew over it I'm going to
think about this all the time why did I
fail man I'm cool I didn't do anything
wrong oh I failed because the world
sucks the world's against me
all the reasons that people make up not
even makeup all the very valid reasons
that you were stopped if you have a
fixed mindset you're going to tell
yourself that you're going to take those
excuses because they make you feel
better about yourself and in that moment
of emotional crisis that happens every
time we fail you're going to reach for
whatever makes you feel better
if on the other hand you have a growth
mindset when you hit that moment you're
going to be like okay cool I need to get
better at this I'm going to have to
transform my potential into usable skill
set and then execute against that then
you can reformulate or hypothesis come
up with a better action to do run that
and even though it will fail again to
some extent you'll have made more
progress and when you iterate on that
Loop enough just relentlessly getting
better trying new things making
incremental Improvement
then you win and that is the only path
to success rule number two is have a
plan with Brendan burchard do you have a
plan is it written down is it on a wall
is it executable
is it a plan that serves your business
growth goals
but also your lifestyle your life goals
what happened is this person you know is
an eight-figure type person in the
industry you know launching doing great
launches and
I'll just share it with you very unhappy
and their team very unhappy their
sentiment that's why I started with that
their positive sentiment in the business
was so low even though they're like
cranking winning launches one after
another
but the whole team the whole vibe the
positive sentiment was low
and coaches in the room you got to
remember you're always listening for
that you're always listening for energy
always like you want to create a great
connection with people start with energy
so it's how I always get to the root of
something with somebody or I notice
something right off the bat is just
where their energy is at and that for me
often guides the conversation so I
noticed positive sentence of this person
their key person and two other marketers
that they had I was talking with them
all and it was just like
a negative sentiment
there was a sense of frustration and
burnout and they were all just kind of
tired of up and down up and down up and
down busy not busy not and for those who
run teams before
you know what was happening
with it was always like what's the next
launch what's the next launch they were
also burning through team members
who didn't enjoy what was happening
there because they didn't know what was
going on there was like no plan
there was no rhythm as we'll talk about
and so if you think about the next six
months of your business again which is
your Super Bowl in our industry
like what's your plan
what's your plan this month next month
the month after that the month after
that
get together a plan if you don't have a
plan yet
you're still like I don't know what I'm
gonna offer or I'll figure out my new
offer next month you're cheating
yourself and you're gonna fall into a
lower sentiment you're going to
experience less progress
don't keep thinking oh I just need to
keep learning I need to keep learning
put a plan in place make a decision
what's the offers when are we going to
launch them what's the Evergreen what's
going to be running like one or two
serious decisions today about your plan
changes everything
the benefit that many of you have as my
friend does
is they have money
you know they have sufficient money to
survive
sufficient money to have abundance or
give something kids and what I found
over and over and over in this space
specifically people with money
more often than anyone else fails to
make a plan
because they don't have to
and this is a you know a transition
they're transitioning from one thing
into another they're in a moment of
transition
and so they're like you know what I'm
comfortable I'm safe I actually don't
have to do anything
you know
I'll just keep learning I'll keep
engaging I like the learning but at some
point they never make the plan and that
cheats them from the progress that
cheats them from the impact and then
their sentiment goes down even if
they're in the right group or they got
the good business or they do know how to
help people they just never made a plan
and executed it and people like you in a
group like this there is a high
achievement mindset that needs to know
that you are executing against the plan
this is what happens when people retire
they had a plan in their career they had
work plans and teams and then they
retire and they forget to make a plan
and a month goes by they're all right
maybe even a year even two years of
decompression
but at some point they kind of could
start
not just going stir crazy
they lose self-esteem
their mental health goes down
humans are gold driven human people we
we have to have a goal a plan and be
moving towards it to sense to sense that
we are activating our potential our
sense of our potential
is often tied to having a plan
does that make sense your sense your
children's sense of their potential is
often tied to having a plan
there's a lot of kids in college as
example great capabilities great
potential but they don't feel like it
because they're just stirring through
classes all the time they're stirring
through social situations there's no
plan in place which sometimes feels
great you're in transition you're
seeking something new you want a little
more spontaneity wonderful
but in business it kills your progress
in business your team gets the hell out
of there
in business you lose the drive
so please be honest with yourself about
the quality of your plan over these next
couple months and if you haven't just
taken the time to make one make one
you you don't even you don't need well I
need to go watch a YouTube video on how
to make a plan no
you need a piece of paper and right at
the top p-l-a-n
and just write out your plan
that's it you don't need anything more
in your life to make a plan today
no more podcasts no more instruction you
don't need to log into tone product
blueprint no no what's the plan make it
up just make the decision
get going rule number three is maintain
a white belt mentality with Robin Sharma
as you get more traction around your
Ambitions as more people follow you as
people fall in love with your magic as
you
raise your game here's what's going to
happen there is a brainwashing process
and a heart washing process and a great
human seduction that happens to almost
every creative person and every leader
you fall in love with yourself you
actually believe your own media releases
and it happens to so many people
and they lose their humility
and it's so profound one of my favorite
stories is there was a
Roman slave in the ancient days named
anoriga and his job was simply this to
stand behind the military commander
called the Ducks and Whisper into the
ear of the military commander Memento
homo Memento homo Memento homo which
means remember you're just a man in
other words remember your only human
it is such a great pull when you start
to move to higher grades of Victory to
stop doing the very things that made you
successful to stop learning to stop
going to art galleries to stop having a
mentor to stop getting up early to stop
taking care of your health set to stop
polishing your beliefs it is so easy to
fall in love with success and that's why
being successful is actually very
dangerous because you might stop doing
the very things that brought your magic
to the world so if you want to
continually be upgrading your
performances is to never lose that white
belt mentality never think you're a
master actually one thing about Masters
they never think they are Masters and
the moment you think you are a master
the moment you think you're the most
important person in every room that
you're in the moment that your ego
screams more loudly than your hunger to
grow and represent Mastery is the
beginning of your descent into
obsolescence and irrelevance you are
only as good as your last performance I
remember reading about one of the icons
from Hollywood and he said it he said
I'm only as good as my last picture it's
so easy to sort of hang your hat on
something you did a year ago or five
years ago or ten years ago maybe you
know the great musicians they all have
that in common it's not like oh I did
this album 40 years ago and I'm sort of
still dining out on that Great
Masterpiece the great ones the people of
great influence the people of great
creativity they understand that you're
only as great as your last performance
the elite athletes I've mentored this is
how they see it they say last year's
championship performance is this year's
starting point so look we all want to be
satisfied we all want to be happy we all
want to wake up every day and go through
life feeling a sense of Joy but there is
a great danger in being completely
satisfied when I work with the
billionaires and the titans of industry
and the Hollywood Superstars here's what
I noticed they're never satisfied now
sometimes if you don't manage that
unsatisfaction you're going to be a very
unhappy person I'm just reporting on
reality a lot of the true Titans It's
never enough they are always
dissatisfied they always want to work
their craft better they always want to
have more influence they always want to
have greater impact they always want to
grow their movement so just remember
that first element of this
deconstruction satisfaction
breeds stagnation you want to be joyful
and CR and grateful and yet at the same
time you never want to lose the fire in
your belly to be better to materialize
more for your Primal genius to offer
value to more people and to grow the
very thing that you do rule number four
is have patience with Gary vaynerchuk
the best way to go from a small business
to a medium business
employing patience and doing what you
did to get to become a small business of
course there's strategies I've been very
consistent about this for 15 years I put
out a very simple message that has been
uncomfortably historically true if you
understand where the customer's
attention is and you know how to make
pictures videos and written words for
those platforms you will grow for that
gentleman's business if he got great at
LinkedIn ads his top line revenue would
grow
the question is how is he judging
himself by the way what is even a small
or medium business like what are the
rules of all this it's like is five
million small is 50 million medium like
what is this I'm sure there's some
answer to it if you Google it but
everybody's answer is different right
like what like it's these constant games
of making these things for us you know
what that is that's the 90-day school
grade the are you trying to do for
tomorrow what is that he's going to make
his own subjective call if he's a medium
business or a small business
we're playing dumb games out here oh my
gosh
I love it I love it
Gary you speak a lot what's up what's a
medium-sized business uh honest to God I
I'm with you who effing knows
but really is it 50
somebody help what's a medium-sized
business
[Music]
no no Revenue not people you
five million bucks somebody just said
that's a medium-sized business that's
small to me
that's a business yeah
perspective but this is important to
understand I'm not right I'm not cool
I'm not special it just doesn't work for
my brain
for somebody else a million is insane
that's insane do you know how hard it is
to build a million dollar business
and oh by the way
what about the fact that you change over
time what about 23 or 5 million dollar
business is a medium-sized business but
then you're 36 and it's not or it goes
down like we just we play in these
semantics that don't mean anything
except make us anxious
you speak to patients a lot and I'm very
curious to hear this answer because I am
not patient at all and I'm one of these
people where I have this Grand idea and
if there isn't this outcome that I'm
looking for within the week I
immediately think that I'm failing and
I'm doing a miserable job and no one
cares so if there's anyone out there
who's like me what advice would you give
them in being patient with their
business do you remember in sixth grade
when you had a zit and you were scared
you used to go to school
no but everybody else had zits too
yeah that's my answer to that question I
love that
this this is where humility is a
superpower you may see bravado on stage
my my happiness is grounded in humility
you know what humidity humility looks
like in this scenario
why if you don't think you're important
it's almost like your results don't
matter
who are you disappointing yourself those
are voices that were put inside of you
by somebody else also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be prepared to
make sacrifices with Dean graziosi a lot
of entrepreneurs listen to this or they
want to be entrepreneurs and there's
this new thing out there not new but if
there's this adage that hey millionaires
have multiple streams of income
right
and sometimes I think myself that's a
fact that's not true although it's true
that most millionaires have multiple
streams of income
my experience is that most of those
millionaires got great at one thing
first
and then as they became millionaires
Diversified their income streams to
multiple streams why I ask this is and I
would really like your opinion about it
I see a lot of people doing five six
seven things three four different things
trying to spin all these plates but not
really getting great at any of them
and I almost think to some extent that
they would be better off if they got
great at something same time I
understand the world today is a
different world than it was 20 years ago
and I really don't know your opinion
about this and I'm curious as to how you
feel about it should someone get great
at what they're doing you spent spoke
about greatness earlier or you believe
or they should have four five six
different things going at any given time
I think the biggest disservice you could
do to a new entrepreneur is tell them
that they should have multiple streams
of income because they'll never go deep
enough on one thing never go through
enough pain and enough failure on the
one thing that'll go deep enough to give
them the breakthroughs to be able to do
that later on in life it's an absolute
fact and here's something before I get
there I want to say something I love the
fact of what this device has done for us
that you could log in and listen to Ed
right now I died I listened to Tony
Robbins tapes when I in 1990s I don't
know 96 95 I listened to Tony Robbins
tapes and when I got done I ordered his
power talk and I'd wait for them to come
every month and I was I was searching
for you to be able to have access in a
second to Ed and Andy frisella and Tony
and and so many great people out there I
love that part but the other part where
I think it's done a disservice to a
whole generation is you think success is
easy when it's brutally freaking hard
it is hard to have the success you want
it's hard to have a jet and freedom and
extra houses and it takes hard work and
it takes time and it's there's no
shortcut I don't care what anybody
thinks there's no shortcut maybe you
could have bought Doja coin and you got
lucky that is the rarest thing in the
history of the world Ed and I I would
bet we agree I don't even know neither
one of us probably invested in crypto
and all of our friends said to because
we didn't know it we didn't feel it and
we missed it so I'm so blessed if you
did for you but that's not where true
wealth is made you have to work 50
harder than you think you do you have to
get kicked in the teeth more than you
think you have to get questioned by your
friends and family and look like the
dreamer twice as much as you think the
people you thought were going to support
you aren't some people are going to talk
behind your back some friends are going
to leave you and guess what it's worth
every freaking Penny it's worth every
moment every disappointment there was a
gentleman named David keckage I met a
muse paralyzed from the neck down and
not always paralyzed I think it was a
jogging car accident and and he had
these keckage credos it was like a
business card that folded out and one of
his keckage credos to make him positive
most positive guy you ever met couldn't
move anything below his neck
was one of them was living the hard way
is easy and living the easy way is hard
so before I answer this about multiple
streams of income I think it's really
important I tell you this living the
hard way makes it easy it was hard when
my friends were partying everything I
still had fun don't get me wrong but
when I was getting up at five o'clock
going to work every day my friend's like
oh you're crazy we come from a small
town it's blue collar just I grew in a
similar town as you did all my friends
are going to be mechanics or
construction workers and if they're
lucky they work for IBM right and when
they told me that I was crazy for doing
it when I worked seven days a week when
I borrowed money when I used to take
credit cards and apply for ten at once
so I could get the money and use that
money and leverage it and go buy a junky
piece of property and fix it up every
night I work on cars during the day I
drive a tow truck at night and I'd work
on my houses at night I'd put 20 hours a
day everybody my sister my family my
friends thought I was insane I was nuts
I was a dreamer people without
educations without money they don't
really get there what were my chances if
you looked at the percentages you
wouldn't bet on me if you were in Vegas
but I knew I took the hard path didn't
know I was but I took the hard way but
now now I get to be the dad I want I
take my kids to school every day I coach
little league I coach softball I can
jump on a plane and go to New York and
go to my farm in New York and spend time
it looks beautiful now but I put the
work and none of it was handed to me now
I'm not saying me but it's easy to sit
on the couch order pizza and binge out
on Netflix that's easy it's hard when
you're 60 and you got diabetes and you
can't play with your kids it's easy in
today's world to go hit up the girl used
to hang out in high school and be
unfaithful and nobody will ever find out
it's easy to do now it's really hard
when the fan and you're alone when
you're 70 years old I know that might
sound harsh but I think through all of
this so first off I want to tell you
live the hard way now make the smart
decisions now so you can live easy and
have choices that you want you don't
have any baby boomers I meet that took a
job that seemed easy and and a nice 401k
and they're 62 years old going I just
wasted 40 years of my life building
someone else's dream and I have my own
help me Dean and I want to help them but
they didn't take the hard way so take
the hard way work hard and you think
secondly multiple streams of income are
absolutely amazing once you crack the
code once you have something steady from
one thing give you Tony Robbins for
example number one personal development
guy no one I don't think anybody will
ever reach his height of success I don't
think anybody will leave the Legacy that
that man's going to lead do you know he
was 48 years old before he invested in
another company and it's because when he
was younger he used to hang out with
billionaires he coached a lot of these
guys when he was in his 20s and he was
on a jet with really successful people
and they're talking about all these
different businesses they have but they
were in their 60s he was in his early
30s and he's like man I'm working my
tail off on one business these guys are
flipping companies and making billions
and a guy said all one of the guys on
the plane I think was the second richest
man in Canada said to him all in your
own time man go deep on your company
when your company is paying then you
could take the money from that company
and there'll be a time in your life
where you can start investing in other
companies but don't do that until you go
deep to know it till it become is
bulletproof it was almost Tony was
almost 50 Ed before he started investing
in other companies now he has multiple
streams of income but he went deep and
mastered what he'd done and here's the
last thing I'll tell you when you master
something doesn't mean you have to stick
with it forever right I mastered real
estate I got really deep but all those
principles I learned in mastering real
estate and hiring people and running
businesses and I took that and they lent
great for my next companies rule number
six is improve your confidence with Ed
mylett when you have a worth level or a
confidence level that you can achieve
something you're far more resilient than
when you don't have that
there's all these tools on confidence
that everybody teaches right but I had a
really profound experience when I was
young that changed my life and and I've
never linked my ability to build a habit
or my confidence to my skill just stay
with me even though I built great skills
I won a contest in Hawaii I'm 28 I'm
running down the beach in Maui running
the other way and that is why you get
rewarded for getting up before the sun
running the other ways is bald I could
see he's got a hairy back he's sweating
he's running towards me
and he's wearing a Sony walk man I'm
wearing one too that's how long ago it
was so we're listening to cassette tapes
when we're running right and so he runs
Miami and it's Dr Wayne Dyer whoa who's
a hero of mine and I said Dr Dyer you
changed my life
and he turns around he's a deep voice
like I do he goes well I highly doubt
that he goes I'm sure you changed your
life but what did I do to help you and
he walks towards me and we sit down on
this beach together and for 90 minutes I
watched the sun come up with Wayne Dyer
and he gets to know me and then he
pouring into me and at the end he goes
Ed You're Gonna Change the World
how old are you at this point 28. wow he
probably said this to some other people
right and he goes I just think you're
brilliant the way you can articulate
your thoughts your viewpoint on personal
development changing oneself your
experience with your dad you're going to
change the world and he goes and that's
not why
and he goes it'll be very dangerous for
you to attach yourself to your abilities
the rest of your life Wow
I said I don't understand like if I
can't close or persuade I can't close a
sale if I go no no I want you to have
all those things but if you attach your
identity or Worth to the external
it's fleeting that's why so many pro
athletes when their career is over they
don't know who they are and I said well
then what do I do and he goes what's
beautiful about you Ed is your
intentions
you have beautiful intent
and I knew that about myself was my
intentions of what I didn't know is he
was writing a book at the time called
The Power of intentions and he goes
would you please please because you you
have the talents would you please attach
your confidence and your worth and your
identity to your intention when you walk
into a stressful environment remind
yourself that you intend to serve you
intend to give because you may lack the
ability sometimes that you may lack the
answer sometimes but you'll never lack
the intent and that intent will put you
in a state where you can find the
answers brother all my life most of my
confidence has come from driving here
today
I just intend to help people I intend to
make a difference I don't like that I
don't need to be here I'm rich already
forget all that stuff my intentions are
to help people we're getting my current
status one way or the other and so I
would recommend everybody to take a real
look inside you what are your intentions
your intentions to make a difference
your intentions to love people your
intentions to serve people it's your
intent to serve your family it's your
intent to make a difference if that's
the foundation for your worth
and your self-confidence you'll never
have to chase it again if it's something
aside from your skill I got to get a
towel I got to get this you'll be
chasing it all of your life now having
said that I have a chapter on habits and
how to develop them and how to create a
trigger and how to create the the
behavior and then have a reward when you
do it so habits are created by triggers
then there's the behavior then there's
the reward and I talk about how to build
those habits but all of that is is
really not very productive if you don't
have some internal knowing that you
deserve to be successful that there's a
worth to you that a confidence that
exudes from you rule number seven is
diversify your cash flow with ramit
safety and I forget who said
diversification Is for Suckers it was
somebody huge yeah and they're right but
only if you get it right exactly odds of
you getting it right oh my God they're
vanishingly Slim So This is it's the
same reason that people chase money or
fame there really is utility to it so
money is incredibly powerful and it's
why AI people can't stop themselves from
trying to get rich even though I don't
know how many people have to tell you
that if you're chasing money you're
going to end up emotionally bankrupt
it's just ruthless they don't believe
you though they don't until they do it
they have to do it themselves and make
the mistake but the reason that that
won't go away is because money actually
is powerful yeah the reason that the
idea of the crypto bro whether it's
crypto or anything else is that when it
hits for somebody it really hits man and
it is transformational and they tell
everybody about it and it's for that
person
it's probably real like and so everybody
chases that one it's like somebody
becoming a movie star you go I want that
if that if Tom Cruise sits here and says
well let me actually explain the
statistics of how many people were in my
class and how I'm the only one who
everyone's like whatever Tom I just I
want to be like you and so
it's okay if that's what you want to do
then God Bless but you need to
understand the game you are playing some
people go I am going to give my entire
life to try to be Tom Cruise
okay do you understand the trade-offs
and maybe it will work one in a million
one in ten million okay
but what if it doesn't work
so this is a common thing for
entrepreneurs as well I have a lot of
entrepreneur friends and we talk about
what are we doing with our business and
our money and you wouldn't believe it
but very few of them invest in the
market and I go what if you don't invest
in the market you're rich you have a lot
of money but let's put it to work and
they go dude they look at me like dude
I can make way more putting it in my
business than putting it in the market
which may be true in the short term but
I go you're right you should probably
invest aggressively I mean your business
is great I have nothing to say about
your business but also say how many
businesses do you know that were around
for 60 years
Sears even they went out like big
companies go out I say why take the risk
of going from here to here
why not take some of your cash flow
and diversify it makes you sleep at
night if something catastrophic happens
to you or your business you and your
family are taken care of like why not
and that that is a productive
conversation because I think business
owners they kind of get risk they think
about risk a little differently
honestly you know I don't want to scare
people with money where it gets most
exciting for me is people who go okay
I'm ready to invest I just don't
understand it those that is an amazing
conversation because in the course of
a couple of hours you can change the way
somebody thinks about money if they're
scared of money if they talk about it
with their partner with money and those
are the people that are ready to make a
change and Rule Number Eight the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is be obsessed with Grant Cardone
Society is labeling numbing people down
to average man if you could just be
average then you'll fit in but that's
not who changes the world that's not who
makes a difference that's not who crates
Industries that's not who gets the
freedom they want and as long as I
fought that okay for the first literally
45 years of my life I've fought this
idea that I would be rich I'd be famous
I'd have the hot chick all these things
I I bought it because I had people
around me saying dude don't do that you
say too much you have no filters you
can't control what you say I mean you
see this in society you know my mom
maybe my mom was like Hey Grant you know
you're fine just the way you are and I'm
like well that's good for you to say you
know people people like the whole
Therapeutic Community says you need to
love yourself the way you are dude no
you don't if you know you have more
potential you should not love yourself
just the way you are if you why would
you lie to yourself
people need to find their obsessions so
that they're not averaged like if you
don't find the things that you're
obsessed with if you don't find those
things then you're just going to be
average you're going to be in the
passenger or somebody's seat and
regardless of where you are in your life
now whatever your excuses or your ideas
are or whatever is going on in your life
whether you've got kids not kids or
young or old
you know I've been in every situation in
my life that
you know something awful and what did I
want to obsess with about at that moment
did I want to obsess about how
limited my options were or did I want to
obsess about how much potential I might
have had in that moment to change my
life
first and foremost we are going to have
to figure out what exactly has happened
so
is it that you don't have a dream or
passion because you haven't taken the
time to
Define that because let me be very clear
passion is not
an archaeological dig
it's an architectural build
so you don't turn in words look inside
yourself and find this glowing Ember of
passion and excitement
that's been sitting there since birth
despite that some people will tell you
that that's how this works but it is not
if Steve Jobs were born a thousand years
ago he would not have dreamed of making
the iPhone what ends up happening is you
decide
there is something that you decide means
enough to you that you're going to
invest in it and then over time that
investment turns that thing into a deep
and abiding passion as you get better
and you get feedback from the world that
they value this thing that you're
getting better at but it isn't just
lying dormant within you and this is
like the number one confusion that I
encounter with people is they think that
either they're broken and other people
were born with a passion and they were
not
or
they just think that
you know if I do enough introspection
I'm gonna find something sitting inside
of me and finally my life will be
amazing
once you realize that in fact what
happens is when you look inside all
you're going to find are these Sparks of
Interest
and from that spark of Interest
through pursuing it as
a process of gaining mastery
it will become a passion when you're
able to use that skill set that you
gained in the pursuit of Mastery to
serve not only yourself but other people
okay so doing that now you're in this
passion Loop of you worked really hard
you gained a set of skills allows you to
serve other people they give you
feedback oh my God thank you this is so
amazing I'm grateful for what you've
done build created given me whatever the
case may be and that feels good which
makes you want to go get better and
that's the passion Loop
now as you're doing that
you're able to really be energized by
the things you're doing
but it doesn't start by looking Inward
and finding something it starts by
realizing that you have to Fan those
flames of that spark of interest to turn
it into the Raging Inferno that you want
to feel of that passion but that comes
from that Loop
okay so that's the first thing to assess
now if you already have or had a passion
but this job has somehow beaten it out
of you that's a very different story and
so if that's what's going on we need to
figure out what is it in the structure
of that that is robbing you of that
what's going on exactly that's making
this overwhelming or stressful or not
fun is it politics in the office is it
just the work environment is too fast
paced is it that you're not being honest
with yourself about you know going back
to this idea 50 of you is hardwired 50
of you is malleable if the hardwired
part is out of step with the life that
you're trying to lead there can be a lot
of frustration there so having the
self-awareness to understand did you put
yourself in the wrong position are you
trying to be Steve Jobs when you should
be Steve Wozniak that's a really
imperative thing to look at now I find
that a lot of times uh companies have
their own issues whenever you get a
large group of people together there are
going to be weird things that have to be
navigated but at the end of the day
while you can can't control everything
that everybody does you can always
control how you react and so you can
reorient yourself within a company to
figure out one if there's a
a path back to finding that Joy but that
comes from breaking down what exactly
happened that made you stop feeling the
joy and two are you able to perform at a
high enough level that you're able to
create the space for you to get back on
track because if you're going to go in
and try to move things around and make
some changes within the company or
within your role or within how things
work you're gonna need to be performing
at a very high level to have the
credibility to make that ask and this is
where it gets difficult nobody wants to
hear this I get it everybody wants to
point fingers and say this is just a
toxic company but in reality if it's
that bad leave do not waste time start
find another job first I'm not just
saying quit find another job but get out
of there don't act like you're actually
in prison you are not actually in prison
and yes I understand that you have
obligations and you may be a single
parent with kids and huge responsibility
I completely understand and I have the
most empathy for that in the world but I
want you to understand
you are only as trapped as you allow
yourself to be if you have a useful
skill set you will be able to find
another job and now is the time to go
looking for that while you're still
getting paid
now if you don't have skill set that's
marketable that's where we have to start
and so building up the skill set
so that we can be marketable somewhere
else that's going to give us the ability
to perform where we are or leave if it's
too toxic but assuming that we're going
to stay now we need that skill set to
perform at a very high level to create
the credibility to make the ask and go
to your boss or whomever is creating or
maybe not even creating the problem but
who has the ability to help you create
the solution now you go and say I'm
performing at a high level yes yes oh my
God you're amazing okay cool here are
the things that I would need to change
so often people's first instinct is just
peace out and they don't realize that
there are many things that they could
have done
to restructure the role to create more
space for themselves in order to stay
but what people end up letting happen is
they let themselves burn out and then
they want to leave and go somewhere else
not realizing that they will have the
same problem at the next job and instead
of doing the work themselves solving the
internal problem of how we ended up here
whether it's lack of skill set not
setting boundaries whatever the case may
be but keeping that ownership keeping
that responsibility recognizing that if
you make different choices you get
different outcomes so that you can go
ahead and change things there now again
if you want to leave leave by all means
take your skill set and go elsewhere but
make sure that you're not doing what I
was doing in my early 20s when I was
about to move to New York because I was
unhappy in LA and I thought the LA was a
problem in reality it was my mindset
once I changed my mindset suddenly I was
amazing
because it wasn't about la
it was about me and I thought ah like
something's got to change and so I just
wanted to go as far away as I could but
it wouldn't have solved the problem I
would have gotten to New York only to
have the same issue again and again and
again
I had to address my mindset and once I
did that then everything changed
so be very careful be very thoughtful
about
how you approach unwinding this problem
if you're always blaming other people
you're not going to get where you want
to go because you're not looking for the
things that you can do differently your
letting your psychological immune system
take over make it other people's
problems and then you're not able to
change
and once you realize that your life is
an exact reflection of your choices
now it's not so you feel bad it's so
that you remember if you make different
choices you get different outcomes and
so now you can make these changes or
gain more skills or whatever it is
that's needed to get the life that you
want now no matter where you go you will
feel completely comfortable that you can
shape things to your liking but you have
to know how the game works
you have to know that building skill set
is the key you have to know that
communicating with your boss what's
working what's not working and to have
earned the credibility to make the ask
do all that you'll have no problem
there's no question that that that
capitalism
as it gets more advanced will widen the
gap between the people that have Market
skills whatever that market demands
and uh and others unless government does
something in between which say the
earned income tax credit or all kinds of
things and and I think that's a proper
function so I would I would I would say
that if people
it isn't some diabolical plot or
anything but look at it this way if you
go back to eighteen hundred and eighty
percent of the people were farmers and
you were the best farmer
in Omaha and I was the worst the
difference in our value might be two to
one you might be worthwise as much if we
aren't there picking one or whatever we
might be doing or plan again uh but
now
there's we'll say two million times
there's 30 million
American males between 20 and 35.
and if you're in the top one tenth of
one percent in basketball ability or
football ability or baseball you aren't
worth anything
if you're in the top hundredth of one
percent you're getting close so
if that's if the payoff is huge because
some guy discovered television many
years ago and another guy discovered pay
TV or cable and then pay TV so that your
talents
where Ted Williams got twenty thousand
dollars a year for batting 406. your
talents now if you if you make the
majors still doesn't pay well on the
miners but if you finally get to that
100th of one percent now you're you're
worth millions and uh one tenth of one
percent you can I don't think you can
just play Sandlot ball and so you get
this pushing of extreme rewards to
people who are very very good at
something the market demands and people
demand entertainment they demand people
apparently that Arbitrage Securities
here I mean there's all there's certain
Specialties and uh
that isn't because a bunch of people are
sitting in a room deciding we're going
to figure out how to take it away from
the poor or anything like that it's
because of the market system but we want
the market system to keep functioning
that way but we don't want people left
behind in a society where you've got
sixty thousand dollars plus of GDP per
capita it uh and that
the people on the on in the lower half
have been getting falling behind the
gains overall achieved by the country
and we've
they aren't worse off than they were 20
years ago they're somewhat better off
and they're better off they're better
off because of things like an iPhone I
mean you know that's that's something
that's terribly useful and and everybody
I get the benefits of search you know
for nothing it'll basically and but
that's the ultimate tension is how do
you keep a system that produces and
incredible benefits for everybody you
know Sports is an easy example because
we all like to to watch them we don't
want to watch a bunch of guys like you
and me
so that's where the money is but that
didn't exist 200. how do we address that
we address it through things like the
earned income tax credit and we address
it so that anybody that worked 40 hours
a week
and as a couple of kids that they don't
need a second job in the family they can
have a decent life does that mean
increasing the minimum wage it means
increasing their income tax credit
because I think that's a better system
yeah what they need is more money in
their pockets yeah now you can do more
money in the pocket through a minimum
wage but you don't have work have as
many people working yeah you need
something so they have money in their
pocket right and we can do that and that
does require
a in my view it requires higher taxes on
people that where they were born into
this world with peculiar talents that
that marvelously now and then 200 years
ago they would have been out there
picking corn with me can you take the
higher taxes on wealthy people and put
it directly to the Earned Income Tax
Credit well you could I mean because
people complain oh my taxes are going
well they're squandering yeah nobody
likes taxes yeah but if you put had a
program where it was earmarked well
that's that's what people do in their
whether on the debate stage you know
currently it's the Democrats and they
they tell you all their new programs and
how they'll pay for it but they don't
tell you how they're going to pay for
the ones are already there nobody's
discussed the trillion dollar deficit we
have so to talk about how you're going
to introduce some new but based
basically
you don't want to run deficits
indefinitely that increase the
relationship that the G because there's
there's some point at which that causes
real problems although we haven't seen
it a lot of places that you might expect
to see it but
this country has
the the productive capacity
to let people like me live
extraordinarily well or sports stars or
entertainment stars all kinds of good
managers whatever
and still make sure that nobody is
really
left so that two people have to work and
you have to hold two jobs and you wonder
how you're going to feed your kids if
you're if you're working you know 750 an
hour doesn't do it and ten dollars an
hour doesn't do it but we can do it we
have the resources to do it we would all
love all of our numbers to be smooth
lines up and to the right and that would
be terrific but that's not how it works
you know um you know the those numbers
are are output measures and you I mean I
guess you could try to manage your
quarterly earnings very precisely but I
I think personally that would be a
mistake you know most of the work that
we put into
um
any particular quarter happened years
ago so it's not you know there's there
aren't that many knobs you can turn
during a quarter I mean you can but
they're very they're like eating your
seed corn if you turn those knobs you
don't want to do that and so uh it's
it's a uh you know people I think if you
focus on the controllable inputs to your
business instead of the outputs in the
long term you get better results so the
the Benjamin Graham quote here is the in
the
short term the stock market is a voting
machine in the long term it's a weighing
machine and I think people are well
advised to build a company that wants to
be weighed and not voted upon and that
means having good return on invested
capital and having you know lots of free
cash flow but if you said to me if I
said
here's a job I would reject if somebody
came to me and said Jeff I want your job
to be to
drive up the Amazon stock price and just
manage that directly now this might
sound ridiculous to some of you but many
companies actually do this they have
they actually go out and they try to
sell the stock that's kind of the final
output and it's much better to say okay
let's not do that that's not going to be
sustainable it's kind of a silly
approach
what are the inputs to a higher stock
price you say okay well pre-cash flow
and return on invested Capital inputs to
a higher stock price okay so let's let's
keep working backwards what are the
inputs to free cash flow and you keep
working backwards until you get to
something that's controllable
and a controllable input for free cash
flow would be something like lower cost
structure and they back up from there
and you say okay well you know if we can
improve our picking efficiency in our
fulfillment centers and reduce defects
defects are very very costly it's
probably you know reducing defects at
the root is one of the best ways to
lower cost structure and so
if you then that starts to be a job you
would accept you would say if you're you
know a reasonable person you would say I
have no idea how to uh drive up the
stock price I can't manage that directly
it's not a controllable input but I I
can make your picking algorithms more
efficient and that will reduce cost
structure and then you know follow that
chain all along the way that's what you
do in all of these businesses when I
analyze businesses
whether they're startups or doing a
hundred million dollars in Revenue
doesn't make a difference
usually there's something in one of
those three or all of those three that
is missing and so when we start to focus
on getting the inner game right plus
what you need to do and then you do it
the results are pretty easy so here's
what I want you to ask yourself
are there people out there
all right that could buy your product or
service but you don't know how to reach
them
right is it possible that there's people
out there that need what you have your
product your service your knowledge your
skills whatever it is that you're
selling offering to the marketplace is
it possible that you just don't know how
to reach them so that means that it's a
skill set issue right
now in 2021
we know how to do those things there
like I said earlier where I started
right the fact that there are two
billion people a day online
means that there's more than enough
people to get in front of listen in the
old in the old days right
um when we didn't have the internet we
had to advertise you know the newspapers
postcards magazines radio television or
set up a store in a shopping center
but now just about every single business
okay is online offering information
content to develop a relationship and
rapport with prospects and they're
taking them through a process Yellow
Pages that's right thank you Muse Debbie
Debbie Muse right so yellow pages so
here's the thing one of the formulas
that you must figure out is where I
started before
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
the added version to that is traffic
times conversion plus repeat business
and referrals equals exponential Revenue
traffic times conversion equals Revenue
Now traffic times conversion plus
referrals and repeat business equals
exponential revenue and so one of the
things that you need to be thinking
about okay and if this is the only thing
that you leave today I'm going to give
you a couple things number one is I need
to adapt I need to adapt to the market
and use all the tools available to me
but not use every one of them I want you
to ask yourself the question I posed
earlier is what has to happen in order
for me to just double or triple the
leads that I get
leads the the prospects coming to see
you online or offline if you just
focused on that question
what has to happen in order for me to
double or triple my prospects or leads
and I'm not sure who said that you
picked up the answer Virginia yeah this
is
this is my New York Times best-selling
book The Answer uh if anybody's read it
uh it is a New York Times bestseller for
many many many years now one of the best
books on the inner game and outer game
of business
uh I put that back over there on my on
my thing
um but I didn't come here to to sell you
on my on my book I want to give you
information if anybody wants to get the
book on Amazon uh for 15 or less
um it'll blow your mind and the Lux
Coast you're reading it now awesome so
when we understand there's already a
process in place
and we discover how do we take our
product or service and create the
marketing how many of you are you good
in marketing
are you good in marketing meaning I'm
not talking about branding I'm talking
about getting your product or service
with the right message in front of the
ideal client
if you're not good at marketing okay I
want you to let me know are you good at
marketing yes or no so you're not good
at marketing
think about this if you're a business
owner there's a couple of different hats
that you have to make sure are being
taken care of right in business if
you're a business owner with a product
or service you have to have somebody
who's doing the marketing right which is
developing your brand creating your
messaging for how you're going to
promote your product or service to
people who don't know you you have to
learn how to sell and selling is doing
something for somebody not to somebody
uh you need to learn how to manage you
need to learn how to either develop
products you need to learn some of the
technology needs that you have there's a
lot of different hats that you have to
wear
uh or you have to make sure that
somebody in your company is wearing that
hat right and so imagine if you're um
needs surgery but you're not a good
surgeon what would you do you'd have to
find how do I get somebody who could do
the surgery so for those of you who are
not good at marketing or sales which is
the oxygen required for any business
regardless of how good your product or
service are the question you want to be
asking yourself is this who can I hire
to help me or who can I barter with to
help me who can I partner with to help
me do my marketing and sales if you're
not good at that so higher partner
barter or defer payment to get it done
because without
marketing and selling
you really don't have a business and
those are skills that either you have
that you need to develop or you don't
have you're not good at you don't want
it but you still need to figure out as a
business owner how am I going to get it
done your job as a business owner is not
to do everything but to make sure that
everything that is oxygen and is
required gets done to change your life
you have to be willing to change your
actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing
different things otherwise you will stay
stuck forever I was doing an Instagram
live yesterday with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say
I'm not comfortable doing that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of the day it's what it is
you're afraid of being judged and so
we're not comfortable doing that thing
you'll you'll fail if nobody else sees
it if it's just you but you don't want
to fail in front of other people and
that can no longer be a good enough
reason because if you only do think
about this if you only do what's
comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what do
what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs is you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
it's actually the opposite because you
are uncomfortable doing it now you have
to do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other store you're gonna tell me
afterwards I have to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is a thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him
anytime you hear yourself say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountable said you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
as that's not against your value system
right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I want to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 we had 23
cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour instead of
just doing a small tour of three cities
or something like 23 cities 90 days you
know core of the year on the road
straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respect comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things the willingness to show up even
if you don't win
[Music]
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today looked the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before is why most people do not
like their life is why most people drive
to a job that they hate
they're driving to a job that they hate
most people wake up all you know look at
all these cars here most people here in
this parking lot they're picking up
every day and driving to a job that they
hate they do not like their life most of
the people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life
and so the answer is to catch your
trigger words so I call them play bigger
triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing
now try to get to the reason behind the
reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear not the
microphone I don't know what to say uh
all of these those are the practical
reasons right those are not the real
reasons the real reason is buried
underneath the Practical reasons why do
you think that having the right camera
and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we were afraid of one people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone bad camera bad
microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
of failure if it's fear of not being
good enough if the fear of being
imposter if it's fear of being
uncomfortable whatever your actual fear
is that's your trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period
so catch what your trigger word is and
I'd love to even know in in the comments
below if you want to leave what is your
trigger word that when you say it when
you text it when you think it when you
feel it that has been holding you back
and that you no longer wanted to
so let's put it in the chat and let's
relieve
a little bit of that pressure that that
word holds over us
so you can actually go build the life
that you want
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want some incredible success motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there here's the hard
truth about getting great it takes time
and dedication it takes a willingness to
accept that you're not yet good enough
it takes the ability to stare at the
places that you know that you're weak